[Music]
welcome to another episode of AI the
future of us a podcast Style video
series where we explore the ways in
which AI is shaping our future and how
we can prepare for the changes that lie
ahead I'm your host Priyanka Regatta and
today I am joined by Arwen hauzhenga the
developer advocate for vertex AI he has
been doing a lot of work around machine
learning and generative Ai and I'm very
excited to have you here all right
thank you very much Priyanka thanks for
having me thanks everyone for uh
listening or watching
amazing so okay so we'll Dive Right In
could you please tell us a little bit
about your background I know a lot about
your work but for everybody else your
expertise in Ai and and
um everything that's been going on yeah
thank you uh yeah so I've been in the
field for machine learning for more than
more than 10 years uh when I started my
career it wasn't called machine learning
it was called Data Mining statistics
advancing analytics back then so I
started at a startup and early on I I
learned that data and sort of data
science was the future so I started
developing myself in the into that
direction so I was working as a data
scientist and then at some point in my
career I got hired at Google which is
already almost six years ago long time
flies when you're having fun and at
Google I've been always been working on
machine learning and some of my focus
areas are mainly machine learning
operations large-scale machine learning
and like you said Priyanka nowadays
generative AI as well that is amazing
the part that I love about that answer
the way you described your journey is
also for anybody who's like trying to
build their career in AI I think I
picked up a set of subtle points in
there it's like it's not always called
the same things you started with data
mining now it's eventually it was data
science and then now it's all these
Muddy Waters of data engineering data
science yeah it's all like sort of
coming together at the same time so
um for anybody out there who's looking
for info on like how you evolve careers
like that was a great example right
there
um with that let me move to my next
question uh could you share some key
developments in AI that you've witnessed
during your 10 plus years of career yeah
I think that there's been a lot Priyanka
and I think you made a great point right
things things change over the years as
well and and we've gone from indeed
statistics data mining Advanced
analytics into data science and now
machine learning large-scale machine
learning and of course generative AI so
we've seen a lot of developments and at
least I've seen throughout my career in
this field and I think some of the key
developments I've seen and we you you
just mentioned them as well are first of
all I think we've moved from sort of
um analytics statistics applied to sort
of smaller data sets and basic modeling
and the organizations and developers
have been doing throughout the years to
sort of the era where we went from this
batch and statistical modeling into more
deep learning more advanced type of
machine learning and that has been a
game changer I think for a lot but still
was sort of a niche right so we a lot of
folks a lot of practitioners they needed
to be an expert on writing especially in
the early days uh challenging tensorflow
code or you use other libraries to build
your neural network so you need sort of
that theoretical expertise and you need
to know how to write code and how to
then also deploy these systems in
production so which was always
challenging but what we've seen now
throughout the years is that cloud
computing has made that a lot easier so
that was a big differentiator as a big
difference for machine learning as well
and it made it easier for all of us to
do machine learning and to do production
machine learning and then nowadays in
the in the past year or years we've seen
of course genitive AI in large language
models come up and have another push and
also we'll probably talk about this
later as well sort of help with that
democratization of AI and open up
machine learning and machine learning
abilities for more folks outside of the
the machine learning PhD space to call
it a bit like sort of the expel expert
space and where more and more folks can
leverage the capabilities of AI and
machine learning that and I think that
has been one of the biggest changes I've
seen throughout throughout the years as
well especially the last the last years
and cloud computing and apis and a lot
of the new technology has been driving a
lot of that
yeah and and with the Advent of cloud
computing more people can actually
explore and use machine learning and AI
without even having to know machine
learning and AI like I remember the time
when we launched automl for example like
just being able it's it's not generative
AI but it is
still no code a being able to create
machine learning models and then from
there to here it's being able to create
our own generative AI models that can be
deployed without much of coding is is
absolutely a you know an amazing amount
of progress so coming to the impact of
AI in your opinion what are the most
significant ways that AI is currently
impacting us Society developers like
it's impacting a lot what do you what
are your opinions
well you you already gave one of the
answers Priyanka so I think I I totally
agree with you democratizing AI is one
of the biggest uh changes we've seen in
in the past years and let's talk about
what it means and what it means for for
folks out there so I think it mainly
means that AI is more accessible for
people outside of sort of the specialist
realm of knowing machine learning in and
out so more and more developers are
getting access to apis or to our automl
so it's more accessible for other type
of practitioners as well business
analysts our accessing machine learning
through maybe things like bigquery ml so
there's a lot of more access to these
Advanced AI capabilities and what we see
also is that these developers are using
these capabilities to build new types of
use cases and I always give the example
of a a scale up that's running on Google
Cloud that's
headed by a good friend of mine and they
build their whole startup around apis
and automls and that gave them the
ability to apply these very Advanced AI
capabilities very quickly and also skill
very quickly across use cases across
different regions so democratizing AI is
definitely one thing that we've seen be
sort of driving a lot of chains recently
but also the way we interact with AI and
I think Bart is a great example of that
as well is that the way we interact with
AI I think is for a lot of folks out
there is becoming more and more real
right in the past what we've seen is
that machine learning was driving things
like recommendation systems or maybe you
you build a search system or a fraud
detection system that we see a lot so
this is typically hidden sort of for um
consumers or for users of of platforms
but now I think it's more real for
everyone and what the capabilities and
the impact of AI can be so it's way more
visible as well I think outside of the
space of of practitioners so I think
that's something I've seen chains in the
in the past years as well so this
reminds me of and the way you are
answering it as well was was very very
similar to the time when Cloud was
evolving too right like
this was like 10 ish more than 10 years
ago when Cloud was evolving we we used
to find it so hot so amazing to be able
to just deploy something so quickly and
having a virtual machine just at our
fingertips on the click of a button
versus asking an IT team to actually
give us a machine right like that that
type of
um I can like relate to that with AI now
where it's like I can build my own model
I don't need to be a data scientist I
need to make sure that I have decent
amount of great data and then be able to
build these models that's kind of big
that's kind of what I'm thinking right
now
it is and do you still remember the the
days where we had to buy our servers or
we had to install our servers yeah I'm
happy that those days are over as well
um exactly and I think that's exactly
where where Ai and ml is leading as well
which is we wouldn't have to worry about
what infrastructure these models are
being trained on or run on we will care
more about just that little part of the
of the puzzle which is how do I enable
my business use case with AI and and
here's my data please train the model
for me when it comes to Industries the
different Industries are going to adopt
AI in different ways so how do you see
AI evolving in the near future with
um with impact on different Industries
yeah I think well I think there's going
to be a lot of impact in in the coming
years and we've already seen this
happening I think in the past years
mainly also because of cloud as you as
you pointed out
um Priyanka is that now we're gonna see
I think more especially more and more
adoptions of natural language type of
use cases thanks to large language
models thanks to generative AI so when
we talk to developers when we talk to
customers organizations working on AI I
think everyone now sort of have it has
an understanding of the impact that AI
can offer and some of the things it can
do so folks are thinking about new use
cases so every time I talk to developers
I learn about the new use case so I
think we will see a lot of different use
cases across a lot of Industries one
that I see on a daily basis because
um and my wife sees in marketing is that
for example a lot of the marketing Works
he's doing like writing blog posts like
generating keywords out of out of
content you see that a lot of this is
already driven by tools like Bart that
help you write or that give you creative
ideas on writing so you see that there's
a lot of impact already in in different
types of organizations that refuse cases
and I think a lot of these capabilities
offer a lot of value for for folk but
I'm hoping also to see a lot of use
cases in things like the the medical
space or Healthcare so that we can also
have a have an impact there and that's
something I'm seeing as well and hoping
that we can drive more chains as well
with all these enhancements with uh with
AI becoming more at the fingertips
um the people who are building these
models and people who are responsible
for creating
um these experiences uh should follow
some general guidelines and principles
um so what are some of these guidelines
on responsible AI that we should
consider When developing Ai and I know
we follow some at Google
um so can we dive a little bit into that
because I think that's something that
everybody is worried about right now
yeah that's that's a great question
Priyanka and I think we we can do a
whole podcast on this topic alone so
I'll I'll highlight a few that I see
that are important for teams or the
teams like to think about right and I
think for every organization and every
team these might change and are
different so I think the first thing is
that it's very important if you work on
these use case use cases to have a
discussion with the business with the
technical teams with everyone involved
to understand stand for your use case
what is important for you because I
don't think there's one template that
works for everyone but a few things that
we've talked about is Google and that
you can read up online as well is that I
think there's a few things that are
important and I'll quickly highlight
some of them is that taking a
human-centered design approach is very
important I think the way users will
interact with the service You're
Building I think in understanding that
is very important I think having that
grounded in the start of your project is
is going to help you a long way
then I think what is important is that
identifying multiple metrics to do your
evaluation so not looking at one metric
but looking at multiple metrics will
help you understand your model better
and secondly also thinking about what
are some of the metrics that we want to
monitor in production so when we have an
AI system in production how are we going
to measure performance or any issues so
having that giving a thought early in
the process is very important as well
another thing that's very important is
test test and test so keep testing keep
improving keep learning as a team and if
you have that mindset I think then that
will help you a lot as well and the last
thing I want to point out is that if you
understand and can look at the raw data
so not at the features that you
generated or someone else's has
generated for you gives you a better
understanding of the data so again and
this this I've learned since the
beginning of my career everything starts
with data high quality data so if you
have access to the raw data if you can
also have a look at the raw data I think
it's going to help you better understand
your data and also build better systems
and also help with with building more
responsible systems as well outside of
these points I mentioned there's many
many more and like I said we can do a
whole whole podcast on this for younger
these are great these are great pointers
human-centric approach continue to test
make sure we you monitor your your raw
data and then uh it's this whole
iterative approach right you don't just
do this once you continue to evolve
improve and and that's how the model
works for the user that you're building
it for but also for
um in you know more responsible and
ethical ways
um
with that what are some examples of how
AI is currently being used effectively
in our Industries yeah I think Priyanka
we see a lot of them right when we talk
to developers there's so many cool great
use cases and
um so some I see across Industries and
I've talked about this a bit already is
a in the Healthcare in the medical space
I see a lot of impact we recently
published
um something around met Palm 2 so a palm
model that is um sort of developed for
the medical domain for safely answering
medical questions and we've seen that
this model has performed very very well
on some of the benchmarks so keen on
seeing how this will impact a lot of the
the medical and Healthcare use cases in
the future as well another interesting
area that I've recently seen because I
was one of the mentors in one of the
Google accelerator programs for startups
on circular economy is that how these
circular economy startups are leveraging
some of these AI generative AI
capabilities to to work sort of to make
the world a better place and to and work
on things like having less waste or
optimizing some of our supply chains to
be more efficient and to have less waste
so I see a lot of different use cases
and I'm always surprised about how
creative folks are with with use cases
as well but these are two that I thought
were very very cool
really cool I've heard that mad Palm 2
has also been able to clear some medical
exams which is like it blows my mind
that is how you trust these models right
if
you trust a Doctor Who's gone through
these exams and
um in these models are are being trained
on the same type of data so
um that is all very exciting uh how can
how can companies and individuals best
leverage AI to improve their operations
and to achieve the the business goals
that they're trying to achieve yeah this
is this is this is a key question I
think I I get a lot from from developers
but also from from business folks
um
there's a lot of answers we can get but
I think two are crucial and I typically
give is that I think everything starts
with the use case
so identifying The Right Use case is is
going to set you up for Success later on
so having a discussion with it with um
with the business and aligning on what
are the expectations what is the use
case we're trying to solve is first of
all essential and AI in itself shouldn't
be a goal solving a specific use case a
specific problem that should be equal
and secondly what I think is very
important once you get started think
about what are the capabilities that are
going to help me solve this use case but
also bring things to production as
quickly as possible so we can iterate
and test like you talked about as well
Priyanka and how I typically like to
look at this when I and how I discuss it
with developers and practitioners is
that try to go from API
to automl to building a custom model so
let's say first try to see if a API can
solve this problem if not try to see if
automl can solve your problem if not
then it's time to build a custom model
because if you start with the apis first
and you can use an API it's easier to
get started it saves you a lot of time
and it's also easier to to sort of
manage things in production so going
through that as well I think is is
important for folks to do that to look
at
all the three points you mentioned are
like so important for startups and for
companies to think about AI is really
not the goal that's how you actually
make
um your use case happen if at all right
sometimes you don't even need AI to make
your use case happen which is why you
have to start with the use case and then
again you don't need custom models
unless you really really have to build a
custom model because for those who've
done it we'll tell you you do not want
to be in the business of building custom
models because they are hard to maintain
they're hard to build so all of that
um thank you I think that was like if if
if anybody watching is taking just one
thing out of it that answer was was that
has done it for me what are some key
skills that individuals or people
um who want to be in the theater One
World should possess to be successful in
this yeah world yeah that's a great
question I know we talked about this in
the pastor of Priyanka I think this is a
question we we get a lot and I'm very
excited about this because this has I
think changed a lot if you would have
asked me like five years ago
like I would say go go study something
like
math or computer science right go work
on on machine learning use cases try to
build machine learning systems work with
tensorflow like a lot of that stuff but
it's it's still there if you want to be
a machine learning practitioner that
maybe does research or that builds these
custom models that you talked about as
well but I think there's also a now a
second sort of way to learn about this
is that because of all these apis automl
capabilities is that you don't need to
be an in and out expert on machine
learning machine learning theory no I
think some of the skills you can learn
are sort of maybe identifying what is
The Right Use case as you mentioned I
mean what are some of the capabilities
out there like apis like automl that
they can use for these use cases maybe
what is it like a structured data use
case versus what is it unstructured data
use case so some of these fundamentals
right and I think think when you do for
example the machine learning crash
course that we have on Google or there's
some courses on identifying use cases I
think that is a great start and then
getting familiar with some of these
newer capabilities like automls or or
apis I think will help you a lot and I
don't think it takes a lot of time to
sort of get started with this and I
think that's a great starting point as
well for folks and especially if you're
new to this just and then Implement a
few use cases right get hands-on
experience there's a lot of great
examples out there we also launched so a
bit of a Shameless plug we launched a
new repo on Google Cloud GitHub on
generative AI that gives you a few
examples on how you can use the API to
build some of your use cases easily so
so learning about use cases learning
about some of the capabilities that are
there on expression on clouds and then
getting started I think that is a great
way to to get into this
Yeah you sort of
you sort of in what your level is is
right like where do you want to start
and and this example of the GitHub repo
that you launched is like the perfect
way to start where it's like okay this
is this is kind of okay this is my level
I'm getting it or if you start with
something like building a custom model
and you're I think there's more chances
of like you quitting that path because
you're like this is too hard I don't
know if ml is for me
um but if you start with something like
that a little bit more handheld
um you you start to understand
um okay it's approachable and then
eventually if you have to build your
custom model you at least know the
parameters and and where to start
um so I love that talking about use
cases you mentioned use cases what are
some of the lessons that you've learned
working on implementing a large number
of use cases as you talk to so many
customers yeah I think that important is
an important Point as well is that like
when it comes to use cases I think it's
very important to sort of identify the
right use case
so um you mentioned this as well is that
like not
you don't always need AI to solve a use
okay so what in which you for which use
cases do we need Ai and and then how
what is the approach that we're gonna
gonna take and also I think aligning
with folks for example in the business
or other stakeholders like how we're
going to measure success what is
important for us and also how we're
going to learn and improve we talked
about testing we talked about an
iterative process so I think again I
think identifying The Right Use case
identifying the the kpis that you want
to measure on the impact that you would
like to see I think doing that early on
is is very important and then it starts
of course everything starts with data do
we have the right data what's the
quality of the data do we need more data
and luckily nowadays I think which is a
big game changer as well thanks to the
automls thanks to the apis we don't need
enormous amounts of data right we can do
it with less data to get started
anything so getting access to the data
and making sure it's it's clean make
sure we understand that data correctly
there's nothing wrong with it I think
that's the second and then we talked
about this then identifying are we going
to use an API are we going to use automl
are we going to use a custom model I
think thinking that through discussing
that I think then the next step and then
it's just getting started uh I think uh
after some point we know what we want
let's get started and let's see if we
can Implement something and I think that
has been something that's changed over
the years as well that it's so much
easier these days to get started I don't
need to get that server that we talked
about and install it and and maintain it
and all those things now it's just one
click of button and we can we can get
started which I think is fun
it's so fun yeah it's so fun to not have
to deal with like these
underlying infrastructure that powers
any of this it's just fun to think about
what do I want to build and then exactly
do I have the data for it let's go
search for the data and start building
so if I was a student right now yes it
would be so much fun to build projects
because the tools are easy to use and
you just make whatever is in your
imagination actually come to life which
is amazing
um so looking ahead what do you believe
is the most exciting potential
application of AI that we have yet to
see and you can go
open all the doors like whatever is
coming to your mind whatever craziness
is going on this is probably the most
difficult question because my
imagination is not that not always that
great but I think seeing what genitive
AI can do is just for me it's it's
mind-blowing right and I think netball
was a great example and you mentioned it
like passing like one of the medical
exams it's it's that is so impressive
for me already so I'm very curious to
see what's going to happen in in the
future I think a lot I think what will
happen is just a lot of folks will
actually take this technology and
Implement new use case so I'll probably
be surprised every day by what people
people build so we've we've seen IO and
we've seen some interesting use cases
there for example
um I think Wendy's was there so I think
a lot of these great use cases but I see
I the biggest change that I think we're
gonna see is the way we're interacting
with applications maybe the way you're
booking a trip right you can ask the
system to do a lot of you for you right
maybe give you a flight give you the
hotels give you some good restaurants
right all those things the way we
interact with technology at Priyanka I
think that's going to be the the biggest
Game Changer in the in the next years or
the next decade
yeah
um both of those things right the way we
interact and well and then earlier you
mentioned this as well the way we build
things the way we build and accomplish
our use cases and the way we interact is
all changing significantly even today so
what advice
um would you give to people in
businesses and individuals that are
looking to prepare for the future
um in which AI plays this such a
significant role I keep this very short
because I think we covered most of this
right and I don't want to be in repeat
mode is that I think identifying The
Right Use case
having a good data strategy and don't
build everything from scratch
so I think if you follow those three
things you'll get a you'll get a long
way
um so we talked about those in more
detail already
perfect yeah no that was amazing very
Punchy
um as we look ahead into the future and
we have been for the entire episode
looking ahead into the future what do
you believe are the most critical areas
of research and development that need to
be addressed yeah it's that is there's
so much exciting uh research happening
but I think a few things that we're
going to see especially in the domain of
transitive AIS large language models or
probably areas of
um responsible AI so
trust and safety of course I think we
see we'll see a lot of research around
this we'll learn about that as well I
think what we're going to see as well is
like how can we run these large models
more efficient and cheaper I think
that's something we're going to see a
lot as well
um it's not always about having the
having the largest model in production
but it's having a the model that's right
for your use cases well and and where
I'm very excited about as well let's
let's talk about some stuff that's not
general or llms or things like graph
neural networks I think that is an area
or or the space of optimization I think
those areas are still also developing
very very rapidly and I see a lot of
great use case for example in the space
of graph neural networks as well like
fraud detection and but also marketing
use cases so a lot of exciting stuff in
research is happening there as well so
um very keen on seeing what's going to
happen in the next next few years
Priyanka thank you so much for joining
me today Erwin thank you Priyanka for
having me and thanks everyone for
listening or watching
on the impact and effective use of AI
and how we are going to get there and we
look forward to seeing how AI will
continue to shape the future around us
and
um we will bring more exciting guests
just like Erwin uh to give us even more
insights and into training and building
these models
foreign
[Music]